[موسيقى]
عياده همسات السكون الاول من نوعها لانها
تعتمد على الطرق الجديده في العلاج للصحه
النفسيه وايضا الطرق القديمه ولكن ايضا
الجديده فانستعمل الفن الموسيقي وايضا
مستعمل التقليدي اللي هو الجلسات الفرديه
وايضا الجمعيه
ونستعمل ايضا
العلاج بالمشي مثلا بدل ما يكون في المكتب
ايضا يمكن نتمشى نتكلم عن الاشياء في هذه
الاشياء اللي هي مش تقليديه وكل الهدف
منها انه الشخص يكون مرتاح في اي نوع من
البيئه عشان يتكلم عن امور بنفسيه
المعلومه اللي انت بتعطيها على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعيه يجب ان تكون اولا
صحيحه
ثانيا مبتكره ثالثا وهو الاهم ما تكون
ممله
[موسيقى]
عندي رساله
لكل النساء والبنات انه هذا التخصص من
التخصصات اللي في كل مجال فهذا الشهاده
يعني سلاح تقدر تستعمليه في اي مكان وفي
اي تخصص وفي اي بلد